to be here tonight to prevent the water
to drip we're on live TV okay off the
stage I don't care this is live
television dude off the stage sorry
ladies and gentlemen I don't know
exactly what's going on I've just been
informed that the monitor upstairs shows
a giant robot mechanical monster is
smashing its way down the street outside
directly toward this theater I am so
sure
and now our first nominee
want to Oscar or you'll tear my head off
my body well Oscar
yesterday you did in today's call you
did a judge everything we already gave
that Oscar out sorry good loser and then
they're asked to do you turn difference
- yeah 10 seconds
can we discuss this oh my god oh yeah
can never find a water cup when you need
one
why
yeah
all right we it's safe to continue
giving the award now
thank you
I'll be right back to be the Oscar as
soon as I change out of my pants
as I was saying I'm so happy and
thrilled to be here tonight the nominees
for best achievement in live-action
short films are making waves and Wingate
producer Ray's male heterosexual
dancehall Johnathan Sanger and Jonathan
Mandel producers shoe shine Robert a
cat's producer and the winner is Ray's
male heterosexual dancehall Jonathan
Sanger and Jonathan the male producer
Brian Gordon whose width Rhea tivity as
director and writer of Ray's male
heterosexual dancehall brought us here
tonight I'd also like to thank David
Putnam who helped us and gave birth help
us give birth to the Discovery Program
I'd also like to thank Don Steele and
Columbia Pictures for helping find a way
to keep the program alive I'd like to
thank Hillary rips and our office staff
for incredible support I'd also like to
thank Tiki Goldberg and Steve Anderson
our production staff and especially all
of the sponsors who proved that the
generosity of the Hollywood community
was the real discovery thank you very
much